what we're doing in this segment of the
program and this is in honor of Shireen
helping us out in a pinch a draft a
special draft address we usually do the
draft at 8:35 a.m. Eastern but we wanted
to do the draft while we're still on
NBCSN a draft of the most unexpected
performances in NFL history best
unexpected performances in NFL history
Shireen I will defer pick number one
round one to you that's the best part is
getting to pick first Mike I like coming
on here because I get to pick first I'm
gonna go with max McGee Super Bowl one
first Super Bowl catch in history this
is a guy who caught four passes in the
regular season and guess what he broke
curfew the night before the Super Bowl
imagine in the age of social media if
that had happened the night before the
Super Bowl but he ended up catching
seven passes for a hundred and thirty
eight yards and two touchdowns and
really probably should have been the MVP
of the Super Bowl as well as he played
but it's hard to go against max McGee
stepping up the way he did in an
unexpected circumstance he was a great
pinch-hitter in that game oh absolutely
and he was on my list and I don't know
that I've made him first though
see I like I like it when I don't have
the first pick and the first pick is one
that I wouldn't have picked because for
me the all-time great unexpected
performance came during the 2001 season
it relates to a guy we've been talking
about throughout the course of the show
today because when Drew Bledsoe got
blown up sir by Moe Lewis on the
sidelines early in the 2001 season and a
guy named Tom Brady gets pressed into
service a guy who was the 199th picked
the year earlier a guy that nobody knows
anything about a guy that apparently not
a whole lot of people paid attention to
in college even though he was pretty
damn good at Michigan he comes in and he
systematically gradually methodically
helps position the New England Patriots
to get to the playoffs to win playoff
games one of the best playoff games ever
that snowglobe game the last game ever
played at Foxboro Stadium goes to
Pittsburgh and somehow beats the
Steelers although he was injured in that
game and Drew Bledsoe came in to save
New England's bacon then Brady gets
thrust back into it quarterback
controversy some people want a blood
oh they go with Brady a lot of pressure
on Brady in the Super Bowl he doesn't
blink wins Super Bowl 36 over the Rams
one of the greatest upsets of all time
who would have ever dreamed that going
into that season a guy named Tom Brady
that not many people was even aware was
in the NFL would end up being the MVP of
the Super Bowl and end up delivering the
way that he did
again I've anticipated your first pick I
anticipated you would take Tom Brady and
I kind of left him for you there Mike
kind of set that up for you but my next
one is gonna be a guy we've also talked
about on this show and a guy who also
came out of nowhere even perhaps more
out of nowhere than anyone else proving
that life is stranger than fiction and
it's Kurt Warner obviously went from the
stalker boy putting up the things in the
the cans in the grocery store to playing
in various leagues to finally getting
his chance in the NFL and it took a
injury to Trent Green in the preseason
for Kurt Warner to be able to play that
season led the ramps the Super Bowl is a
Super Bowl MVP an MVP of the league now
a Hall of Famer who would have expected
that the way his career started and a
lot of people most people probably would
have quit before they got that
opportunity but he stayed at it and
obviously became one of the greatest
players in NFL history at least one of
the top 350 greatest players in NFL
history based on his bust being in
Canton yeah I thought about him or Brady
for that first overall pick and I'll
agree
I remember when Trent Green went down it
was our NBC colleague Rodney Harrison
that hit Trent Green in a preseason game
and that that was it the Rams were done
they were three and 13 the year before
dick for meals basically on the hot seat
and the seat just just was completely
engulfed in flames once he had to go to
Kurt Warner guy who had bounced around
various football leagues and all of a
sudden they they find magic and Kurt
Warner see NFL MVP and they go to the
Super Bowl and they win it so I agree
with you that was extremely unexpected
I'm gonna stay in that same era because
nowadays the great quarterbacks are
coming through the draft back in the
late 90s and
coming through the first round of the
draft in the late 90s early part of the
the last decade you never knew where the
great quarterbacks were going to come
from and it was in 1998 when the
Minnesota Vikings had a team that was
poised to be one of the best offenses of
all time and everything looked great
with Randy Moss and Chris Carter and
Jake Reed Brad Johnson breaks his leg
against the Rams a year before the Rams
had Kurt Warner thrust into prominence
and here comes Randall Cunningham a guy
who had been a good quarterback with the
Eagles good - very good
was out of football in 1996 joined the
Vikings as the backup in 1997 he was
installing marble countertops in
bathrooms and kitchens in Las Vegas in -
in 1996 but in 1998 he gets thrown into
the mix and he has a season for the ages
for the Vikings and they come one Gary
Andersen field goal short of going to
the Super Bowl and who knows what would
happen against John Elway and the
Broncos in Super Bowl number 33 but
Randall Cunningham completely and
totally unexpected had the best year of
his career after his career was supposed
to be over well he sure [ __ ] he sure did
and I was there for that championship
game and they probably should have won
that championship game and didn't get it
done or he would probably be one of the
greatest quarterbacks in NFL history as
well perhaps my last pick Mike I'm
really torn and the - I'm torn between
is Timmy Smith and Earl moral and I'm
going to go with Earl moral because the
1972 dolphins are one of the greatest
teams in NFL history and everybody
thinks Bob Griese was the quarterback of
that team and he was the quarterback of
that team for the first part of the
season then he gets injured the last
nine games in the first couple playoff
games they have to go with Earl morale
to pull this thing out and they pulled
it off and I realized he didn't throw
that many passes they were really really
a run oriented football team and that's
how they won their games even with Bob
Griese
but the fact that he was able to go nine
and know as the starting quarterback of
the Dolphins and now the undefeated
Dolphins the only undefeated team in NFL
history they remain
you got to go with oral Mauro on this
list so he's going to be my third pick
there to be able to pull that off and
win a couple playoff games as well and
you know I mean that that's a great
choice and that's one that but we just
gloss over because you know we talked
about quarterbacks that have won
multiple Super Bowls earlier in the week
and Bob Griese gets the credit but yeah
Earl Morel did a lot of the heavy
lifting that season as the Dolphins put
that memorable year together you know
I've got one that then this one is is is
just for you because I'm thinking back
to a 10 year old
Shareen Williams and you know that her
favorite team with her future husband at
quarterback Roger Staubach but it was on
Thanksgiving Day in 1975 when Roger was
available to go how's it good and in
comes Clint Longley and Clint Clint
Longley and that was for me that was
still in the early years of watching
football and that was the first like
stunner for me that this was even
possible did someone who wasn't one of
the star players somebody that I didn't
even know who he was could come in and
play well that's not supposed to happen
when you put somebody out there that
nobody knows who they are they stink and
they lose and when the Cowboys won that
game that I still that comes up I'd say
at least once a month somehow some way
on this show that Clint Longley
performance and also the the PostScript
to it where what did he sucker punch
Roger Staubach I think he's sucker punch
Roger stop so I'm sure the Clint I'm
sure you didn't have a Clint Longley
jersey well back in the mid-70s but
Clint long that was definitely an
unexpected performance on one of the
biggest games of the year Washington and
Dallas Thanksgiving Day in 1975
yeah and they ended up getting rid of
Clint Longley right after the sucker
punch they said enough of that you're
gone and that was his one claim to fame
in the NFL and I think he's fallen off
the face of the earth now no one could
seem to locate Clint Longley and where
he is people try to do these
anniversaries stories on that game and
can't find him and the Cowboys weren't
good that year either that's the other
thing they didn't have a great team I
don't think they made the playoffs that
season but they had that one great game
that Clint Lolly came in and saved the
day yeah but I keep saying it was 75 it
was seven
for wasn't it was the 74 it was 74 yeah
okay yeah it's 75 because I'm aware that
they did make the playoffs in 1975 I do
recall that I I definitely recall the
Cowboys playing in the playoffs in 1975
they it was that game entailed a nun
called offensive pass interference too
bad we didn't have the 2019 pass
interference replay review in 1975 maybe
the Vikings would have gone to the Super
Bowl that year to lose a fifth one what
ultimately would have been a fifth when
that would have been number four for the
Vikings they would have lost to the
Steelers in Super Bowl 10 but for that
push off by Drew Pearson in the 1975
playoffs so I always get that one wrong
in fact I thought one of the last time
they talked about it I said 74 and then
I thought I saw it was 75 now I know it
was 1974 Cowboys Clint Longley 4 when I
mentioned it again I have a feeling I'll
mention it again at some point all right
we're gonna take a take a quick break
plenty more PFT live still to come but
before that a recap of the draft fest
unexpected performances in NFL history
Shareen has max Magee Kurt Warner and
Earl Morel I've got Tom Brady Randall
Cunningham and Clint Longley
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports